South Korea's response to the
coronavirus has been widely held up as
an example to other countries at one
time it faced the second worst outbreak
in the world after China but quickly
brought it under control by encouraging
people and companies to voluntarily
social distance while conducting mass
testing and contact tracing president
moon jae-in used this national address
to promise further advances we will
reinforce our epidemic prevention and
quarantine systems become the undisputed
number one epidemic response country
leading the world party had a warning
that the world was now on the verge of a
global crisis because of the pandemic is
fundamentally changing our daily lives
and pushing the world economy into an
unprecedented crisis as an export-driven
economy South Korea faces tough times a
global recession means people will be
buying less of what the country makes
while restructuring of industrial
production is likely to further hurt
trade at a national forum a panel of
experts came together to consider ways
for the economy to recover the focus is
using the country's high-tech advantages
like 5g networks and digital systems to
grow so called non face-to-face
industries overall society is
transforming to have less human to human
contact our economic structure has to be
digitalized fast and we will be focusing
on ways to accelerate that moon jae-in
described this national drive as a
Korean New Deal non face-to-face
industries related to medical services
education and retail distribution will
be intensively foster cities and
industrial complexes transportation
networks and aging national
infrastructure will be combined with
artificial intelligence and digital
technology to make them smart
how South Korea performs could have
wider implications just as much of the
world has been watching how it handled
the pandemic so it will be studying how
it now recovers from it Rob McBride
al-jazeera sold